de mettre la table donc quelques
chiffres quelques chiffres pour
comprendre l'ampleur évidemment de
l'opération à l'échelle de la province
avant le grand soir celui d'élections
tout d'abord combien de municipalités
donc en élection il y en a un peu plus
de 1000 1100 trois ans d'élections il y
en a qui le sont pas pour diverses
raisons
lac-mégantic évidemment pour des raisons
tout à fait évidente 8050 deux postes
convoités des postes de maires et
conseillers municipaux 510 mer et 6949
conseillé par contre comme ça il voit
dans le prochain graphique à quatre
municipalités sans candidat à la mairie
alors voilà ça c'est des données qui
peuvent surprendre mais qu'on voit
d'achat qu'à chaque élection à des
degrés divers bien évidemment et
justement d'enjeux d'autres d'autres
données qui peuvent surprendre comme le
fait que dans une municipalité sur cinq
20% des municipalités en élections en
2013 tous les postes seront pourvus sans
opposition aucune
alors voilà en 2013 on dit que c'est 53
% des postes au total ou à peu près qui
seront pourvus qu'ils nous font face
pour lesquels il n'y a pas aucune
opposition
alors pour suis un peu moins semble-t-il
que les dernières années taux de
participation municipale de 2009 sas et
les élections précédentes
45 % à l'échelle du québec si on va voir
un peu plus de détails en fonction des
municipalités les plus importantes dans
la province bat montréal est à 39 % de
participation remarquée que lors de
notre dernier sondage crop radio canada
ont laissé entendre des chiffres et se
croire que la participation serait plus
important de cette fois ci on verra bien
le suspense demeure québec 49% laval 36%
gatineau 39 longuet 39% également 45%
finalement c'est la moyenne à sherbrooke
cinquante deux pour cent à saguenay et
50 2% à trois-rivières voilà pour ces
données on poursuivra avec d'autres
données éventuellement et je termine on
rappellera en rapport en rappelant que
dimanche prochain c'est jour de vote
vote par anticipation pour ceux que ça
intéresse de 12h à 20h
voilà